hey what's going on guys it's rob i hope
you had a wonderful holiday season and a
happy new year if you didn't get that
toy that you really wanted for the
holidays i'm going to show you how to
make something really cool today the
origami boomerang this is definitely one
of my most favorite origami models to
make now it's pretty simple it's fun for
all ages and it will keep you busy for
hours when i first made it i was playing
around with it for over an hour well the
first one i made didn't come out so good
neatness really counts with this model
so you need to be as neat as possible if
you want it to fly well what you're
going to need is a piece of a4 printer
paper that's just a basic eight and a
half by 11 sheet just like this you
don't want to use cover paper that's too
thick you don't want to use construction
paper just use a sheet like this and the
good thing about it is that we're going
to split it in half
meaning you get to make two
origami boomerangs with one sheet now
you're probably wondering how well can
an origami boomerang really fly that's
made from a piece of printer paper well
before we start i'm going to show you a
quick little video of me throwing it
you can try throwing two of them at the
same time
to start off position your printer paper
so that the longer ends are horizontal
then we're going to take the top end of
the paper and fold it down in half to
the bottom end and try to be as neat as
possible and align it edge to edge
perfectly when you do so then you can
make a crease along the top of the paper
and then to split it in half you can run
your fingernail against the edge
if you want to fold it back on itself
and do the same the other way you can do
that
and then we could split the paper in
half
we're going to once again fold the paper
in half lengthwise so take the top end
of the paper and fold it down to the
bottom end of the paper
and make sure that the edges are aligned
perfectly
and then you can make a crease along the
top of the paper
you may want to just run your fingernail
against it so that we have really good
creases
since that will help the boomerang fly a
little better
when you unfold the paper you'll now
notice we have a line that divides the
paper in half and we're going to be
taking the top end of the paper and the
bottom end of the paper and folding it
directly next to the line you don't want
to fold it right on top of it because
when we fold the boomerang in half again
it might interfere with the edges
so take the top end of the paper
fold it down
next to that line leave a little bit of
space maybe like a millimeter or so
and then you want to make a nice crease
along the top edge of the paper
so as you'll see i left a little bit of
space
in between
the middle of the paper and the edge of
the paper there do the same for the
bottom edge so just fold it
directly next to that line leaving a
little bit of space
and then we can make a crease along the
bottom of the paper there
so as you'll see there is a little bit
of space
in between the two edges so that when we
fold it in half
it doesn't interfere with those edges
which we just folded in
all right so now we can take one end of
the paper and we're going to fold it
across to the other end and as you'll
see the paper is very straight
so once you align it edge to edge just
hold it there and you might need to just
pull on this a little bit
to kind of round it off and
it'll allow you to make that nice
crease on the end there and then you
could run your fingernail over it
and then we're going to take both of the
corners here and we're going to fold
them inward so that the top edge is
aligned with that vertical line you see
and you may want to just hold the bottom
here because when you fold this inwards
it will kind of
misalign the paper so you just want to
hold the bottom here
fold the corner inwards just like that
and make a crease
run your fingernail over it do the same
with the left side
so just fold that corner in just like
that
and
make another crease
and you could run your fingernail over
there
then you can unfold both of the corners
and we can just fold it backwards if you
want to flip the model over and fold it
that way it's fine
but you could just fold it backwards on
the same crease which you just made
and run your fingernail over it
do the same with the left side
and
run your fingernail over it
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to just open the side here and
we're going to tuck both of these
corners inwards
just like that so you want to take it
tuck the corner in
and then you want to re-close the flaps
do the same with the left side
open it up
tuck the corner in
and then you can just close
both of the edges together again
make good creases
and you're ready to move on all right at
this point i need you guys to pay really
close attention to listen carefully
since the folding does get a little
tricky here but i'm going to go through
in a lot of detail to make it as simple
for you as i can
we're going to take the model and we're
going to unfold it
and then we're also going to unfold this
edge on the right that we previously
folded in towards the center so you just
want to unfold the right side of the
model
just like that
now you'll see we have a diamond shape
on the right side here
so to make this next fold a little bit
easier we're just going to make some of
these creases here in the diamond a
little better
on this horizontal fold you want to just
take both ends of the model and to just
fold them away from you
and then you want to just run your
fingernail against that horizontal fold
and that's known as a mountain fold
because it creates what looks like a
mountain
and then on the outside of the diamond
here we also want to just make those
creases a little better
so we're just going to flip over the
model
and as you'll see we have the four
creases here
just take your finger and you want to
run your fingernail against the edge
there so you just want to fold downwards
on that and just run your fingernail
against it
and do that with all four
of the creases there
so it should look something like that
now just a little bit better um folded
so now you can flip the model over
and now what we're going to do
is we're basically going to make a
little pocket here
so what we want to do
is we want to take our thumb we're just
going to close the top half of the model
so that this edge is once again on the
midline and just hold it there
and then we're going to take this
diamond and we're going to squash it
just like that
so you want to take your thumb and
you're going to squash this diamond so
that this
corner here
is folded up against
this piece of the paper here
take it and you just want to flatten it
there
against the paper
and then what we're going to do is once
again fold this edge
back inwards towards the midline and as
you'll see we have a little bit of a
pocket here
so this corner is going to be
right in that pocket so you just want to
fold it
into that pocket
and as you'll see the edge once again
lines up and we have created what looks
like a pocket here
so once you have a model like this
you're ready to move on
okay so take the model now and on the
corner here
you want to just make sure that this
crease is good so just fold it downwards
like that and just run your fingernail
against it
then we're going to take
the left side of the model and we're
going to fold this edge down
and when you do that
this little pocket area should kind of
form a little mountain there
then you're going to take the top edge
and you're also going to fold it
down so that this edge here
is on the bottom with this edge so fold
it down like that
and as you'll see that little mountain
area is going to be folded to the left
now and form a little pocket in there
and you can just flatten everything out
and what we're going to do now
is we're just going to reopen everything
and then you're going to lift up this
edge here
so that
you
take this corner that we previously
tucked in
you want to basically just lift that up
like that
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to once again fold this left side
down
and then we want to fold the top down
and when we do that it will once again
form that little pocket in there but we
want to have this corner tucked into
that area now where that pocket has
formed
so just
put that in there
close the top down
and just kind of work that corner back
into that area and make sure everything
is folded nicely
and make really good creases
so your model should look something like
this now
all right guys we're pretty much done
with making the origami boomerang we
just need to lock the ends and to do
that we're just going to open the end
like that and we're going to fold both
of these corners in so that the edge
here is aligned with the vertical edge
so just fold it in and try to be as neat
as possible
and make a crease and run your
fingernail against it do the same with
the left side
and then you could unfold the one on the
right and then you're going to open
the edge like this and tuck this corner
in similar to like we did before so you
just want to tuck that corner in
and as you'll see it forms a little flap
here so just flatten that out and you
can open the left side and you'll have a
little flap here now and then we could
reclose the model
so put that edge back down
and as you'll see you have the flap here
and you have what looks like a little
pocket now
formed by the other flap so you could
tuck this flap into that pocket
all the way up
to the edge uh the crease that we made
there
so just tuck it in like that
and just flatten everything out
and then you can do the same with the
other side
on the left side here we only have one
layer
whereas the other side we had two layers
on both sides but it works the same way
so just fold this in
and make a crease
and fold the right side in and make
another crease
then you can unfold the right side open
this
edge tuck this corner in you might need
to fold it here on that crease
open this flap close the model
and then you can finally
open that little pocket there
and tuck that flap in
all right guys so once you've done all
that
flatten everything out
you have finished your origami boomerang
okay so before you start just make sure
that the model is really neat just like
this one is here and make sure all of
the creases
are very good and the model is flat
if you do bend the model it's not going
to fly correctly so it is pretty fragile
but it will endure being hit against
walls and stuff like that but if it hits
a wall it's not going to come back to
you so you want to hold it like this
with this
line here the diagonal line it should be
facing upwards
so you don't want to hold it with this
little
flap here on the back should be held
like this
and as you'll see this end here is
diagonally down to the right
like that
so this is the way you want to throw it
there is a way to make this
uh so that you could throw it with your
left hand i know there's some lefties
out there me included but i am able to
throw this with my right hand so once
you position it like this you want to
just rotate it like a frisbee and it's
going to be thrown so that the model is
spinning clockwise so you just want to
throw it like that i probably won't
catch it right now but let me try to
throw it
well there you go
so just make sure your model is neat if
it's not coming back to you you need to
practice on how to throw it
make sure the model is very flat and
have fun with your origami boomerang
alright guys thanks for watching and be
sure to subscribe for further
notification of my videos